how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
mcu and today we're going to be talking
about black panther to wakanda forever a
movie that has been
up to this point kept under wraps pretty
well it's been a pretty big mystery so
far
although some things do come out that
give us a little bit of information
about the movie we've had a few cast
members talk about what they've seen and
heard so far
and each of them so far have said that
the movie is
going to work and it's going to pay
tribute to chadwick bozeman in a very
nice way
and that's sort of what we have today
actor martin freeman who plays
everett ross in the marvel cinematic
universe was on a talk show recently and
he talked about
going over the script with ryan coogler
and he described it as
odd and this is the first time that
we've really heard anything besides
really positive words about the script
for black panther to wakanda forever but
this is going to be
probably the hardest film to make
because of the loss of chadwick boseman
especially since they decided to not
recast him so we'll go over what martin
freeman had to say
about the script and about his zoom call
with ryan coogler the director and
writer of black panther 2. also remind
her about my stormbreaker giveaway it
ends at the end of this month all you
have to do to enter subscribe to my
channel and cosmic culture
link in the description down below so
martin freeman who plays everett ross
appeared on the late
late show with james corden and he
teased a little bit of what's to come as
far as his role is concerned and the
entire plot for wakanda forever
while on the show james corden asked him
about the film in which he revealed that
a couple of months ago he had a zoom
call with ryan coogler where they talked
about the script
and this is what he had to say about
that i had a zoom call with ryan
coogler the director and co-writer about
seven or eight weeks ago
i suppose he sort of meticulously took
me through
all of my character's beats in the film
he took me through the film but
incorporating my character's beats and
some of it was
really very odd and i think that ryan
coogler could see from the reaction on
my face to some of the things he was
saying
my face must have had a very shocked
expression on it
because he kept sort of stopping and he
kept going
saying stay with me but this is going to
work
people are in for i think a real treat i
mean we've not done it yet
who knows we might make it awful but i'm
hoping we won't i'm hoping people are
going to be in
for a treat freeman ended the
conversation about this by stating
obviously the hope is we do the first
film justice and we do chadwick's legacy
on it justice and make
hopefully another good film so this is
very interesting but it's also
pretty good keep in mind that martin
freeman could have just thought that
his character's role was pretty odd not
the entire script as it is
other cast members have already
commented on the script stating that it
does a really
really good job at honoring chadwick's
legacy and ryan coogler seems to have
a very good vision of what he wants the
film to be
and he apparently thinks that it's going
to work really really well
on screen he even said to martin freeman
people are in for
a real treat which is great because i
think some people are actually really
worried about the film
especially since they're not going to
read cast t'challa
but cast members like lupita nyong'o who
plays nakia
in black panther stated that the film is
going to do chadwick justice
and the script is very good now so far
we don't really know much about the
actual plot we do have our actor that is
going to be playing the main villain
tanakh
huerta however the villain is
unspecified at this point we don't know
who the villain is actually going to be
however i do have a theory on who he
could be playing
tina cuerta is a mexican actor and
the atlantean race according to
traditional theosophy
includes those of the mongolian race the
malayan race and the american
indian race and since tina cuerta is of
mexican descent he could play
one of these races which means that he
could be playing
namor neymour could be the villain of
black panther 2. wakanda
and atlantis have a pretty big history
together specifically they
are at war with each other in fact in
the avengers vs x-men comic line namor
practically destroys wakanda with the
help of the phoenix force
and another part to kind of add to this
is also the fact that there's casting
calls for
warriors and that's all they really say
about this casting call
now the wakandan warriors we pretty much
already have
they'll pretty much use the same people
from the first black panther film
avengers infinity war and avengers
in-game so the casting call for new
warriors most likely
isn't for wakandan warriors and since
the casting call for
these warriors came out the same time
that it was announced that tenna kuerta
was going to be the main villain
it would make sense that these casting
calls would be for something related to
the main villain as well
so these warriors could be atlantean
warriors
so before the unfortunate passing of
chadwick boseman there were a lot of
reports going around that
black panther 2 was going to introduce
atlantis and neymar in the film
if these reports were true then
originally before the passing of
chadwick there was going to be a battle
between
t'challa and neymar and it was said that
we were really going to explore
atlantis and it did really seem and kind
of does still really seem like marvel
was heading in the direction of
introducing namor and atlantis we've
actually had several easter eggs in the
mcu
pointing towards namor the first one we
saw in iron man 2.
when nick fury is talking to tony stark
about the avengers initiative there are
some screens in the background
these screens are apparently showing
other potential recruits
for the avengers initiative and areas
that shield is monitoring
i don't think i want you looking at that
i'm not sure it pertains to you anymore
if we take a look at one of the screens
in the background we can see
africa and on the screen there is one
circle in the middle of
africa that is wakanda and the second
circle is a little bit to the left in
the middle of the atlantic ocean
that's atlantis there's really nothing
else that could be except for atlantis
and neymar and this is
all the way back in iron man 2 which
means they have kind of been planning
this for a long time now and then of
course we have
the really big name or easter egg which
is confirmed to be
a neymar easter egg by the writers in
avengers end game
in the beginning of avengers in-game
when natasha is talking to
rocket okoye captain marvel and nebula
okoye mentions that there was an
earthquake in the atlantean ocean
and okoye says that the best way to deal
with it is by
not dealing with it now the earthquake
is caused by the atlanteans and again
atlantis and wakanda are usually at war
with another so okoye doesn't really
want anybody to know
about atlantis or the atlantean so she
says we don't deal with it
now when one of the writers christopher
marcus was asked
if this was indeed a name or easter egg
he said
sometimes you plant seeds sometimes they
grow
basically confirming yes we are planting
the seeds for
namor and this would make perfect sense
if they were originally planning on
introducing
atlantis and namor in black panther 2.
and tina cuerta who has been cast as the
main villain still
could be playing namor unfortunately
right now it is not confirmed who
exactly the villain is going to be but i
think it would be really
really cool if it was indeed namor but
let me know what you think do you think
that neymar
is going to be the main villain of
wakanda forever and are you worried
about wakanda forever script
be sure to hit me with your thoughts in
the comments down below don't forget to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all things relating to wakanda forever
and of course the mcu in general
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof
you